trevor is with us in Utah hi Trevor how
are you hey good how are you
better than I deserve what's up so I got
very nervous here okay so my mom gave me
Financial Peace University I went to
class with her cement from them I met my
wife we got married two weeks after that
she started chemotherapy and did the
cancer and so I put off school same with
her and then so that was now last year
over about a year passed since we sent
we had we had to move into her parents
house just through the financial
circumstances but during that time we
happen to pay off about ten thousand
dollars of my debt and but now that were
moved out her parents gave her a call
before I married her they pay the
payments on it but they will give the
title to us once it's paid off but
they're right now asking for help paying
it down but at the same time in six
months for excuse me a year were long
cools out and do an internship for her
and how is your wives how's your wife's
health now oh good she's finally doing
well all go back to normal so the cancer
is in remission yeah every three months
she goes up into checkups um but so far
so good
cool okay and so what do you make a year
$15 an hour I do part-time because I'm
back in school full-time so I think
about 700 a paycheck what are you
studying automotive technician when we
graduate in six months okay
and what does she do and what does she
make right now she's a manager for a
vacation rental property she makes about
the same but on a full-time
for our week let's make seven or dollars
a full-time oh she does
fifteen dollars an hour for forty
dollars an hour forty hours a week
okay but that will change because she
will be going back to school
in August so she'll be kind of back to
part-time same pay as me right now that
make sense mm-hmm and what is she going
back to school for and how are you guys
going to afford for her to go back to
school you're broke we both are getting
a Pell Grant and we get about $1,000
extra [ __ ] leftovers and she has a
scholarship from that I'm in school how
old are you - I'm 23 in cheese 20 what
do you owe on what does your parent her
parents own this car it's right now
$14,000 mmm it's a car you can't afford
yeah so I would tell them to sell the
car okay do you have any suggestions on
how do we bring that up do with them I
we we make no money we are broke we're
both in school we're 23 we can't afford
a $14,000 car we really wish you would
sell it okay yeah I can't I can't
imagine paying payments on anything
right now we're on you know what a Pell
Grant is yeah I know it's for poor
people yeah they don't drive $14,000
cars you're right okay and so you don't
qualify for a Pell Grant if you have a
14,000 on a car and and you shouldn't so
the car needs to go away you guys need
to get a beater car the good news is you
know how to work on cars and so six
months I'm not sure how you guys are
going to eat for the first I think she
needs to put off school until spring and
let you get out of school and start
making some money matter of fact I know
she does yeah
and you guys need to get you a little
one-bedroom apartment it starts your
lives off now that the cancer is behind
you and you need to arrange your
finances in such a way that you're being
responsible and that's an inexpensive
paid for car a couple thousand bucks
one-bedroom apartment she delays school
- you get your 6 months done and then
you make some pretty serious money as an
auto mechanic and support her while
she's going through school and you can
support the family while she's going
through school and then when she comes
out with her digital design both of you
have a good income at that point you're
gonna be doing very well
but you've got to work towards
systematically towards hitting these
goals and that's what it amounts to and
you can work on their deaths as you go
along but just don't be adding any debts
to it you have to pay cash for her
school it's the only possible way hope
that helps you sir thanks for the call
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in we'll
talk about your life and your money it
is what we do here it's common sense
living on less than you make living on
less than you make living on a written
plan no one accidentally wins the Super
Bowl and no one accidentally becomes
wealthy wealthy people starting from
nothing don't wake up and go wow it's an
intentional acts very thought through
matter of planning laying out your life
and saying this is where I'm going and
this is how I'm gonna get there living
on less than you make living on a plan
staying out of debt having money saved
being outrageously generous these are
the formulas for a great life